what's real I don't want sex on the
first day even though I've you know been
caught slipping and it happened but I
don't really want to do it
because I wouldn't either but I know why
for me why why for you well you know I'm
I'm a good kisser hey Usher I'm a good
kisser and I I like to kiss but but I'm
at an age now where I just don't want to
do that I want romance right I Want From
Here to Eternity wins the race yes yes
yes and I don't want to give up my body
first and then you got to find the
matching bra and panty set and get ready
for all of that and lotion stuffing guys
I sure don't want to do all that I want
I want to kiss good night and and go
home and go to bed